[Música]
a mí una persona ya me cambió la vida
esta persona es mi abuelo mi abuelo me
enseñó que la vida de mis sueños está
justo detrás de todos mis miedos hace 50
años cuando la gente no sabía que era un
avión cómo viajar en avión cómo se
compraban los tiquetes mi abuelo quería
recorrer el mundo mi abuelo se soñaba
con ver cara a cara todos esos lugares
que él veían fotos en revistas en libros
y mi abuelo tomo una decisión no sólo se
fue a recorrer el mundo durante siete
años
mi abuelo dejó todo dejo sus negocios su
familia sus empresas por ir a ver el
mundo de sus sueños frente a frente
así creció de la mano de un viejo que
anda enseñándole a la gente que no se
debe tener miedo nada
quiero que me acompañen a este momento
estábamos en la sala de mi casa y mis
papás me hacen la típica pregunta que le
hacen a todos los universitarios cuando
se van a graduar y me dicen bueno lina
ahora que tú qué vas a hacer de que vas
a vivir cómo vas a comer que has pensado
que ya busca hace un trabajo que va a
pasar
yo les dije bueno yo les quiero
compartir que tengo un sueño y ese sueño
es que yo quiero cambiar vidas mis papás
se quedaron en silencio total
y me dijeron bueno pues tú puedes
cambiar vidas en tus tiempos libres en
tus vacaciones después del trabajo
puedes hacer todas las cosas que tú
dices pero por ahora te vas a buscar un
trabajo serio y un trabajo estable
ustedes no se imaginan yo no dormía y yo
pensaba todas las noches yo cómo voy a
convencer a mis papás que yo quiero
cambiar vidas
una noche
en medio de un desvelo terrible yo me
soñé con un vestido blanco con un
sombrero blanco este sombrero estaba
creado por comunidades indígenas
colombianas y yo dije esto es lo que yo
quiero yo quiero crear una marca de moda
sostenible con comunidades indígenas y
que todo el mundo conozca la cultura
colombiana
la gente me empezó a decir cómo se te
ocurre que vas a hacer eso la moda
sostenible no genera dinero eso no es
rentable porque mejor no traes ropa de
china y te dejas de complicar la vida yo
tengo que confesarles que ser la loca en
un mundo de cuerdos y en una familia de
acuerdos no fue una tarea para nada
fácil y si la loca vendió el carro saqué
un crédito en el banco ya que todos los
ahorros que tenía yo cortaba telas día y
noche en la sala de mi casa
volví mi casa todo un taller atendía
clientes servía el tinto yo hacía
absolutamente todo y la gente decía es
que el inah tiene un negocito de
vestidos de baño y ustedes no saben la
ira que a mí me da que me dijeran que yo
tenía un negocito de vestidos de baño
porque es que para mí si esta idea le
iba a cambiar la vida a una persona
éramos un emporio
entonces para desarrollar mi proyecto
decidí empezar a trabajar con la
comunidad indígena kuna doble ellos
viven en el norte de colombia en la
frontera con panamá para llegar a ese
lugar se debe tomar un avión a una
ciudad costera colombia cuatro buses una
barquita un motor ratón para los que no
saben que es un motor ratón es
básicamente un señor en una moto conmigo
horas atrás y un burrito pero en ese
momento ustedes llegan al paraíso el
paraíso es un lugar donde suenan los
pájaros las mujeres indígenas cantando
las olas del mar pegando contra las
rocas
ahí yo supe que estaban lugar donde
tenían que estar pues hasta que en esa
primera visita
nos reunimos en un congreso un congreso
es esto que ustedes pueden ver acá
básicamente es una casa muy grande donde
se reúne toda la comunidad en la mitad
se ponen los hombres autoridad de la
comunidad en hamacas que es lo que es
los que ustedes pueden ver ahí y te
hacen muchas preguntas donde quieren
entender cuáles son tus intenciones si
tú no vas a explotar a las mujeres y te
aprueban o te desaprueba
luego de esa reunión que fue muy larga y
de ser aprobada por toda la comunidad
pasamos a reunirnos ya con las mujeres
en privado en esa reunión con mínimos
nos tomamos algo entendimos todo este
mundo nuevo que para mí era todo
absolutamente nuevo cómo se vestían como
hablaban la forma en que los niños
jugaban para ellos también era súper
nuevo todo lo que yo hacía mi ropa como
me peinaba todo era nuevo
resulta que ellos en esa reunión me
mostraron la mola la muela son los
cuadrados que ustedes pueden ver en el
vientre de las mujeres la moda es una
técnica textil un azul en la mola es
pintada por los hombres y cocida por las
mujeres porque esto simboliza que los
hombres y las mujeres se complementan en
todo la molas del símbolo de protección
de la comunidad y como las mujeres somos
la vida y la fertilidad si protegen a la
mujer protegen a toda la comunidad
entonces por eso la muela solo se ve en
los prendas de las mujeres
resulta que antes ellas salían a la
carretera a vender sus molas y en el
trayecto eran agredidas física y
sexualmente ya que lastimosamente el
lugar donde ellas vienen es muy
peligroso
en ese momento yo me di cuenta que
estaba en el lugar de mis sueños sin
embargo tenía grandes retos de crear un
proyecto que importará en sus vidas y en
mi vida
entonces empezamos a desarrollar
vestidos de baño los vestidos de baño
que creamos son los que ustedes pueden
ver en las imágenes ellas hacen todos
los apliques que están todos con molas
los vestidos de baño y luego los
llamamos a talleres especializados y los
volvemos en prendas que se están
vendiendo en este momento
estos vestidos de baño se crean en
talleres con creativos los talleres son
en la comunidad nos reunimos ellas van
ideas yo les doy ideas yo les muestro lo
que la mujer de la ciudad está usando de
allí salen todas nuestras prendas pero
hay un detalle que ustedes todavía no
saben y es que ellas no hablan español
yo no hablo en su idioma y su idioma no
se parece en nada a lo que ustedes
conocen quiero que ustedes tengan una
breve visión de cómo se ven esas
reuniones y cómo se escuchan sobre todo
[Música]
así son todas nuestras reuniones
allí estábamos hablando de qué tamaño
debía ir la mola para cada vestido de
baño resulta que como no nos entendemos
nosotras nos comunicamos por gestos y
por dibujos estos son el tipo de dibujos
que hacemos en las reuniones nosotras no
sólo hacemos negocios
nosotras mientras vamos dibujando vamos
rompiendo los miedos de cada una de
nosotras mientras vamos dibujando nos
conectamos las unas a las otras así no
podamos hablarnos y comunicarnos
este proyecto y la impactaba la vida a
demasiadas personas a demasiadas mujeres
a mí me ha impactado la vida
impresionante incluso mi familia le ha
impactado mucho la vida pero allí una
historia en especial que a mí me revolcó
la vida y es la historia de fred hilda
ella es prendida frente a las madres en
el gas una mujer indígena kuna doble
prendas la encargada de toda la medicina
ancestral de la comunidad y resulta que
frené hilda en la última reunión que
tuvimos en la comunidad nos hizo saber
que gracias al trabajo en el proyecto
que tenemos ahora puede comprar pescado
para sus hijos
yo tengo que confesarles que yo en ese
momento no podía parar de dejar dejar de
llorar porque para mí que una mamá le
pueda dar pescado a sus hijos hace que
todo valga la pena en ese momento todos
los ruidos de mi cabeza se callaron en
ese momento todos los problemas en ese
momento haber sido llamada loca rebelde
todo eso se cayó y me di cuenta que por
historias como fenil de sus hijas todo
esto tuvo un propósito
nosotras somos 53 mujeres que nos dimos
cuenta que juntas somos imparables
nosotras somos mujeres que le cambian la
vida a otras mujeres nuestras clientas
se unen a nosotras y entre todas nos
cambiamos la vida nosotras son las
mujeres que apoyan los sueños de otras
mujeres yo entendí que esta niña pequeña
que ustedes ven acá que soy yo
tenía grandes sueños ardiendo en su
corazón que hoy toman forma entendí que
cuando una niña tú le dices que no tenga
miedo y que la anp o deras puede
cambiarle la vida a otras personas
gracias a que mi abuelo venció todos los
miedos yo pude vencer los míos y puede
estar con mi proyecto en lugares como el
desierto del sahara por eso en sus manos
tienen un pedacito de mola
quiero que esta muela se la lleven como
un recordatorio que la peguen a una
camisa que la peguen a una almohada para
que ustedes sepan que justo detrás de
sus medios está la vida de sus sueños
pero si yo les pregunto ustedes a qué
miedo le están creyendo ustedes cuáles
miedos están escuchando quiero que les
que este recordatorio de que la vida de
sus sueños y la vida de los sueños de
muchas personas está detrás de ese miedo
al que les están escuchando muchas
gracias